i'll give you probably the most extreme
example of this there's a big debate
that broke out on twitter the other day
the debate was over whether two plus two
equals four or two plus two equals five
i'm not joking
this was a this was trending for the day
people were actually arguing
and the left was arguing that two plus
two can equal five
which is exactly what the totalitarian
regime in george orwell's 1984 says
they say two plus two equals five and
they force
the protagonist winston smith to
acknowledge not even just the 2 plus 2
equals 5 but the 2 plus 2 equals
whatever the party says it is
and this all began because a a meme
maker posted on
on twitter he says woke woke minnie's 2
plus 2 equals 4 a perspective in white
western mathematics that marginalizes
other possible values
it's just a joke because left wingers
have been saying that objective
reason and hard work and even
mathematics is a western white concept
and
people of color should reject that
should reject that idea
right people of color this this way to
analogize through identity politics
the experience of all other people with
black people in america even though
obviously
as we discussed earlier that doesn't
make any sense but then you had
people on the left actually defending
the idea that two plus two equals five
and without going into
the the tediousness of their silly
arguments they said look numbers they're
just symbols right
so we can make the symbols mean whatever
we want the symbols to mean
if we want if we want two to really be
two and a half
then okay then two plus two equals five
because two is two and a half and two
and half plus two and a half is five
and five can be banana and gimbal the
gobbledygook right that the words and
the numbers that we're using they're
just symbols and they have no
no relationship to anything real that's
a left-wing point of view that's a
progressive point of view that we are
not bound by anything real including our
human nature
we can change anything we can we can
change
lies damned lies and statistics right
these numbers don't mean anything at all
all they have to do is fit
our narrative and our narrative is
whatever we will
our narrative to be right this another
big difference here between the right
and the left the
left believes that they can construct
the world
based on nothing more than their own
unfettered
imagination and the right conservatives
know that's not possible there's
something that is
enduring it's called human nature
there's reality right the great
conservative consolation that reality
reasserts itself in the end
this debate over whether two plus two
equals four or two plus two equals five
or can equal five that is at work right
now
in this campaign do we want to maintain
anything resembling our our reality
or do we want to toss it all aside
literally burn the country to the ground
burn our principles to the ground and
reconstruct them
on the antagonistic imagination of the
democratic party
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you